Speaker 1: Georgia Republican Senate candidate
Herschel Walker is very much against abortion.
Abortion is murder.
Abortion is evil.
Abortion is killing.
And it appears as though Herschel Walker paid
for a girlfriend of his to get an abortion.
The last 24 hours have been a historic and
historic implosion for Herschel Walker, and
you are not going to believe what is going
on.
But the real question, as always, is our Republican
voters so depraved that they won't even care.
But we'll get to that in a moment.
Herschel Walker is now being accused and,
you know, accused.
It's sort of like it's only the word we use
because it makes him such a hypocrite of paying
for a girlfriend's abortion.
The woman has receipts and a get well card
that she says Herschel Walker sent to her.
Here's the article about this from The Daily
Beast and the headline.
The top points are Herschel Walker says he
wants to completely ban abortion.
He says it's murder.
He says there should be no exceptions for
rape, incest or the life of the mother.
A woman who asked not to be identified told
the told The Daily Beast that when she and
Walker conceived a child while dating in 2009,
he urged her to get an abortion.
The woman said she got an abortion and that
Herschel Walker reimbursed her for it.
She was able to support the claims with a
$575 receipt from the abortion clinic and
get well card from Herschel Walker and a bank
deposit receipt, including an image of a personal
check from Walker for $700.
The reason for the difference the abortion
costs 525 but the check is for 700, she says,
is because she ballpark the cost to Herschel
Walker after looking up the cost online.
The Daily Beast was able to independently
corroborate details of the claim with a close
friend who she told at the time who took care
of her in the days after the procedure.
The woman said Walker, who was not married
at the time, told her, You know, it would
be more convenient to terminate the pregnancy
if you believe it's murder.
Do you murder out of convenience, Herschel?
He said it was not the right time for him
to have a child.
It was a feeling she shared.
But what she didn't know was that Walker already
had had an out-of-wedlock child with another
woman earlier that same year.
Asked if Walker expressed regret for the decision,
she said, No, he didn't.
Asked why she came forward, she points to
Walker's hardline anti-abortion position.
I just can't with the hypocrisy anymore.
We all deserve better.
So listen, I am not against Walker paying
for an abortion.
Assuming he was not coercive, it sounds like
he was urging the woman to have an abortion.
But I'm primarily against the disgusting hypocrisy
of these people.
And Trump is the same Trump.
I mean, listen, I am not aware of Trump paying
for anybody's abortion and pressuring them
to get one.
It would not be at all a shock if Donald Trump
has sometime pressured someone to get an abortion
and paid for it.
But it's not something I can speak to right
now.
But Trump's story about, Oh, I'm so against
abortion.
So against abortion since being 68 years old.
And up until then, I was very much in favor
of a woman's right to choose.
This is one of the things that would doom
Herschel Walker's campaign, if not for the
sad fact that many of these Republicans don't
read the news.
And if they do, they will assume this story
is a lie.
And if they believe the story, they won't
care.
Here is a montage from Ron Phillippe Koski
of Herschel Walker, very powerfully against
abortion, one gift.
Speaker 2: From God and God told me, thou
shalt not kill.
Remember, my God, I'll run against a woman
to kill my baby.
Whoa!
That's what he said.
He's also said if a baby survived an abortion,
he voted to deny that baby medical care.
And how strange in the past.
I mean, I said thou shalt not kill.
You know, he's seen to be relish on a woman
killing her baby.
He's a pastor.
Speaker 3: So that's the reason most abortions
after 15 weeks.
What's your stance on?
Speaker 2: You know, I believe in life.
I'm a Christian.
I believe in life.
And I and it is strange that my opponent and
no one is talking about that.
He seemed to be really excited about the one
McCain and baby.
Well, what is his term?
It's not right to have the doctor and the
patient and the government in the same room.
And I said, Do you not realize that there's
a baby in that room to believe in?
And I'm not going to apologize for it.
And, you know, and I think she would be in
the States would if I had a vote right now,
it would be.
Yes.
Trying to kind of say I'm a Christian right
now.
You say you're a Christian.
And they said, Hershel, what do you think
of.
He asked me all these questions like, did
I not say I'm a Christian?
That means you're supposed to be pro-life.
I thought.
Speaker 1: Anyway, you guys get the picture.
So let's see what this does to the polling
of Herschel Walker.
The good news is that after Herschel Walker
was very, very, very slim, leading Raphael
Warnock, the last three polls and four of
the last five have Raphael Warnock back ahead.
But it is very tight.
It's within the margin of error.
We're talking about under a one point spread.
So let's give this a week and see if this
is finally the nail in the coffin that we've
been hoping for, for Herschel Walker's campaign,
a guy who has no business whatsoever being
in the Senate.
But it gets even better, my friends, after
this news came out.
Herschel Walker went on the Sean HANNITY program
and then it got really crazy